thank you very much for having me here I
am from New Hampshire so one of the
first questions I always get is why is a
fellow from New Hampshire writing about
a fellow who was born and raised and
lived his entire life in Tennessee and
they're there a few reasons the first
one that came to mind was it's a great
excuse to drink Jack Daniels but then
any money I made off the book would
probably go to my rehab that this the
second reason is he lived in it in a
great period of our history he was born
in 18-49 and he died in 1911 so he came
of age during the Industrial Revolution
the Gilded Age and I love that period
also the whisking and distilling
subculture is just fascinating and
there's just so many colorful stories
it's just fun to read the the fourth
reason really which really got me going
was that I had done this series of
business books and one was on classic
American entrepreneurs and I really
wanted something on Jack Daniel just
because of the marketing I mean this
this brand is an icon it's as
recognizable as coca-cola
harley-davidson in its world-renowned
and I couldn't find anything and I
couldn't believe that there wasn't
anything out there of substance on this
man who had started at all
this was about six years ago and and it
sort of just percolated in my brain and
and finally I decided I've got to try
and get enough material for a book on
this guy
now that brings us to the to the
research and one of the the problems
with researching a character like that
like this is that there is so much
legend and myth that surrounds him that
has actually been perpetuated by the
Jack Daniel distillery and brown-forman
which owns the distillery you know as
part of marketing their product so one
of my tasks was to really separate out
the the myth and
the fiction from from the fact now when
I was working on Carnegie this man kept
every letter he ever wrote or that he
received so there were boxes and boxes
of archived material it was it was easy
to find the sources to bring him to life
with Jack Daniel it was not so easy
there simply wasn't that that body of
work that was easily identifiable and
one of my first stops of course was
Lynchburg Tennessee where the distillery
is and I met with the the media man down
there and the the sort of unofficial
company historian and he said no there
that we don't know of anything part of
the problem was that there were there
were two fires that raised the town of
Lynchburg back in the late 1800s
destroyed a lot of documents also during
Prohibition the company moved from
Lynchburg to st. Louis was obviously
shut down for a number of years and came
back to Lynchburg so again the paper
trail was lost I also met with Jack
Daniels great-grandniece Len Tolly who
you might know she's often on programs
promoting her cookbooks and what have
you and she's a great ambassador for the
distillery and she's one of the she's
really the only one who is a descendant
of the Daniel family who's connected
with distillery so I was hoping maybe
there was some letters or photos
anything that had been passed down
through the family that I could get
ahold of and again you know there was I
came up against the wall so now I'm
starting to panic because I have this
contract to do this book what what I had
to do was really start from scratch and
and this was kind of rewarding because
this was original scholarship and I had
to go to church records I I lived in the
Nash Nashville State Library going
through microfilm I dug into not just
church records but census and tax
information
deeds and in court cases and that's
where Jack Daniel or mr. Jack or Uncle
Jack because he's affectionately known
as down in Lynchburg that's where he
started to come to life and I'll give
you a few examples on the bottle you'll
see that that the company states the
distillery was established in 1866 well
I happen to come across a deed that
showed clearly that Jack Daniel and his
partner Dan call started their business
in 1875 so when it when it came across
something like that you know the lights
go off and it's a really a gold nugget
now that distillery has mixed feelings
about maybe finding that out of course
but that was you know just one of those
classic moments so that was an example
of what I found in the deeds and you can
and and they were very specific about
who was distilling who and other
businesses that were going on at that
time it was it was a great way to start
to piece together what he was doing
another great example is court records
Jack Daniel was involved in a number of
court cases where he had to testify and
I found a beautiful one that involved
two mules mules are or were extremely
important to the Lynchburg area and the
surrounding area as the beast of burden
and this court case went on for dozens
and dozens of pages and yet it was just
about two mules which shows you how
important they were now Jack had to
testify he was a witness so there was
quite a few pages of his testimony and
it was verbatim of course so I could
hear his voice now that's to me better
than actually finding a treasure trove
of letters because you craft a letter
it's not necessarily your voice so I got
to hear Jack the idiom and also whether
or not he was educated and and I
immediately came to the conclusion that
this was a very well-educated man this
was
to backwoods boy who had not learned
much except how to make whiskey so that
was another great find also there were
family histories as you know genealogy
is really big around here and and where
I am in New Hampshire it's not so to me
that was just a great find and in the
small library is not just in Lynchburg
the Moore County Library
but surrounding towns had you know just
rooms dedicated to genealogy and and
families that had recorded their history
and so I started digging into those and
sure enough I found some great stories
about Jack Daniel and and one that was
just an absolute classic was told by
this family about how Jack used to on
Sundays ride his horse out to the - at
one church or another and as the the
young ladies came out of the church you
know dressed in their best of course he
would pay the local boys nickels and
dimes to give him the lowdown on
particular women and and this is how I
started to find out that he was actually
quite a ladies man and he never married
another great source for starting to
piece together his life were newspaper
articles and again that can really be
you know just drudgery just grueling
work going through literally every
weekly issue of the Lynchburg Falcon and
other local newspapers but there was one
that I know there was a bunch that were
great that it came across but one in
particular from 1877 there was a major
piece on the local distillers and in
that I discovered why he calls his
whiskey old number seven what had
happened was the government you're in a
tax district and the government gave
each distiller a particular number to
identify that distillery in that
district and Jack was in district 4 and
in his number was number seven now he'd
had that for a couple of years but the
government decided in its wisdom to
combine combined district four with
district
now district 5 included some Nashville
area distilleries that were much larger
and much more sophisticated than these
fellows down in the Lynchburg area and
that did not leave them happy at all in
fact they sent a couple of their leaders
up to DC to complain so Jack what now
was in district 5 and out of all the
district 4 distilleries that were
combined into five he was the only one
who had his number changed
he became number 16 in district 5 now
that may not seem like a big deal but
back then you sold your whiskey in jugs
and in barrels and you didn't have a
brand name what you had on there was the
government stamp with your district and
your number and that's how your
customers knew you so Jack who made one
of the finer whiskeys decided to heck
with that I'm gonna put old number 7 on
on my my barrels and jugs from now on
and you'll see in the book I discussed
that it went went through he had a bunch
of different names you know old-time
distillery number seven Jack Daniels old
number seven so this was his way of not
just revolting against what the the
government the revenue department had
done but also to remind his customers
who he was so that's where the name
comes from so I started to piece
together as his life and was really able
to flesh it out now I want to give you a
thumbnail sketch of his rise from from
the backwoods to really the world stage
but before we do that we just have to
review a little bit of background on on
whiskey making and his family and his
roots whiskey of course originated in
Scotland or Ireland depending whether
you're talking to an Irishman or a
Scotsman they've thought about it for
centuries what we know though is that in
the 1400s they were making single malt
in Scotland now those whiskies are made
with barley in this country we don't
have barley
so when they started to migrate here the
predominant crop was corn there was a
Episcopalian missionary and you'll find
out that the clergy are always involved
in whiskey making it's great you know
they got to have all the spirits there
was a missionary in North Carolina who
figured out how to distill corn and and
make corn whiskey and he preferred it to
his English ale now unfortunately for
him he proceeded it to give it give it
to the Native Americans who killed
killed them on a drunken rampage and I'm
not sure if they were mad at him because
of the corn whiskey or mad at him
because he was a missionary you know
that's up for debate but - now corn we
have corn whiskey being made here right
before the Revolutionary War people from
Scotland Ireland the Scotch Irish that
came from Ulster started immigrating
here in droves they came through New
York Philadelphia they pushed West to
the Allegheny Mountains and then they
came down the Shenandoah Valley started
settling into Kentucky they also came
via South Carolina and North Carolina
Jack's grandfather came via New Bern
North Carolina right before the war he
fought in the Revolutionary War and
around 1800 moved inland to Tennessee
and then the Jack's father was born
shortly thereafter and it was Jack's
father who around 1835 migrated up to
the Lynchburg area and in the early
1800s that that was still wilderness
they were really pioneers that Daniels
family and a handful of others were and
still are considered the pioneers so
that's how they moved into the area and
what they brought with them of course is
the whiskey making tradition and that is
why Lynchburg and in certain areas in
Kentucky and North Carolina are just so
well-known for their whiskey making
because
of the contingent of scotch-irish
Irish and Scottish folks that that
became pioneers in those areas now as
far as Jax life goes I mentioned he was
born in 18-49 and he died in 1911 he is
and and this was something that
surprised me a classic rags to riches
story when he was born in 49 his mother
died shortly thereafter and his father
remarried but then during the Civil War
he lost his father and he despised his
stepmother so he's essentially an orphan
at that point and he ran away from home
and he had all of nine dollars to his
name now he was adopted by a local
family Dan call who you'll read about in
the legends of Jack Daniel and Dan call
is the one who taught him how to distill
and it was really Dan call who had a
slave nearest Green who then remained
with dan call after the war which shows
you what kind of man Dan call musta been
and it was nearest green who really
showed Jack all the tricks of the trade
because prior to the war it was the
slaves who really developed some of the
techniques that refined the whiskey now
coming out of the Civil War as you know
Middle Tennessee was completely
plundered you know that the Union troops
had come in here in sixty-two ravaged
the place it was their breadbasket for
the next three years so how did you get
on your feet
as a farmer or as a returning soldier
you made whiskey
it was the most efficient use of corn
crop it was also very easy to get to
market you know the corn could spoil on
the way to market but whiskey wasn't
going to spoil so there was a lot of
moonshine going on a lot of distilling
and in these areas and of course Jack
and Dan call we're moonshining in those
years right after the Civil War because
laws were not being enforced by the
federal government at that time and
there's great stories about Jack Daniel
going down to Huntsville you have you
have to read about him
you know he's only a teenager and and
his personal courage really starts to
show now as I mentioned 1866 is the date
the company says that that he started
his business but it's really 1875 so
Jack spent a lot of years learning the
trade and it was a slow process there
was one other thing going on in his life
after his father died the farm went up
for sale and it was sold in 1867 and the
proceeds were gonna be divided among ten
children Jack was one of 10 the last of
ten but the family started feuding over
the money because the older kids had
already been given gifts by from the
father like one had received $500 which
was a substantial sum then another had
received the prized horse so the younger
generation said no no now hold on a
minute
we want our fair share so it was
actually in the courts for a number of
years the family fought it out and the
judge decided that they had to pull
together all of the family's belongings
everything that had been given prior to
Calloway Daniels death and it and when
it was all pulled together it mounted to
a little over ten thousand dollars now
Jack who only had nine dollars to his
name coming into this realized the
thousand dollars plus as a windfall now
that was a huge sum in those days you
could buy a beautiful farm for three or
four hundred dollars the case was
settled in 1875 and that's when Jack
goes into business he buys himself one
hundred and forty acres spread he goes
into business with Dan call now Dan call
is a lay preacher in the local Lutheran
Church he only lasts a few years because
of pressure from his church and his wife
to drop out of the distilling business
and it's an 1884 Jack's now on his own
that he buys the legendary hollow witch
which of course you'll read about if you
go to Lynchburg and do the tour you'll
see the Hollow
okay so now he
is in business on his own and 20 years
later is when he hits the world stage
and that's at the 1904 st. Louis World's
Fair he enters the competition there for
liqueurs for whiskey and of course
everyone is expecting some fine single
malt scotch to take the prize or an
Irish whiskey to take the prize but Jack
wins the gold medal and and it makes big
news among the distilleries because you
know who is this guy well he's he was
known as the little man from Lynchburg
now here's the sad part about this story
in his local paper
he got one little line of recognition
and you know this was a big deal right
next to him you know I was reading the
paper right next to him there was an
article that I got a few inches of press
you know a lot more than you got about a
man living in Chicago who had filed a
petition in court to get an injunction
against his wife to stop her from
talking so here's this ridiculous
article in in the Fayetteville paper and
right next to this court Jack get in one
little line so you know what what is
happening that that just gives you sort
of a sketch of his rise but you know
what's happening at the time that that
that the newspaper would basically
disregard his finest accomplishment well
you have the dry forces the temperance
movement the people who want national
prohibition at work and and they are
coming to the fore at this point they
are they're pushing hard and they've got
a grip not only on politicians but on
the media and you see a polarization
going on in society like like we have
today you know if you look at gay
marriage there's that polarization it
was the same thing back then when you
read the newspaper articles in fact
there were a lot of Local Option laws
that would allow towns individually to
vote to go dry and what would happen is
that the the local preacher or minister
would actually stand at the ballot box
and if anyone voted not to go dry he
would shout out their name
so that was democracy at work in circa
1900 and one of the leaders of course it
was Carrie nation who made headline news
on both sides of the Atlantic and and
she was she was a piece of work and I
have to quote what she has to say about
men
she says that men are nicotine soaked
beer besmirched whiskey greased red-eyed
Devils and this was a woman who was
actually married twice and she had a
child so she was something now something
else I want to mention is Jack of course
was in the Bible Belt right he was
raised in the primitive Baptist Church
and so drinking was frowned upon and as
you read the book you'll see that
there's this constant tension between
the distillers and and of course the the
Baptist Church now coming out of the
Civil War and and through into the 1870s
distillers were very important to this
area because they hired a lot of people
and they brought in a lot of money and
they were community leaders by the time
he gets the 1890s things that
flip-flopped you know we have to talk a
little bit about Jack Daniels the
marketing genius because of course
that's what people think about today and
he he really did start it he really was
the the seed to the kind of promotion
you still see today if you go down to
Lynchburg you're gonna see the the
distillery's calendar with you know good
old distillery boys sitting on old
pickup trucks and and barrels John away
and and and brown-forman
who owns a distillery really has
promoted that kind of backwoods
down-to-earth image and but that's what
Jack was he was completely rooted in the
traditional way of doing things
you know this was a guy who was born in
Lynchburg became famous could have moved
into the glitzy Nats Nashville
and but he never did he really was
rooted in in the past now as far as his
marketing genius you have to picture
this guy he was five foot two as an
adult five foot seven was the average
male height at that time he had a
flowing mustache goatee he had his
signature outfit which you'll you'll see
plenty of photos of which was a
knee-length frock coat silk line vest a
broad tie a wide brim planters hat so
when this guy walked into a Nashville
saloon you didn't forget him
you just didn't forget him and he spent
a lot of time in saloons especially in
the men's quarter here so there was that
image of him that you just simply
couldn't forget now also he had his PT
Barnum side he sponsored balloon
launches which were a big deal then to
bring attention to himself and his
whiskey he formed that Jack Daniels old
number 7 cornet band which you'll see
photos of that's used in advertising for
the product today he even sent a barrel
of whiskey to Queen Victoria and Britain
to bring attention to himself and I like
to say that looking at photos of her
with her stiff upper lip I don't think
she ever had a drop unless it was for
medicinal purposes but so he really you
know he knew how to promote himself then
you have the square bottle from 1897
that's when he adopted the square bottle
and that was partly by luck a company
from Illinois was was promoting this
square bottle and prior to that time
bottles really weren't used there wasn't
the technology to make them on a mass
scale so this the salesman showed up and
Jack said that's the bottle for me that
square bottle will show people that I'm
a square dealer I'm a good guy because
of course distillers had had a shady
image so the company really took that
and ran with it and I should sort of
wrap up here with with what happened in
the last years of Jack's life
in 1907 he bequeaths the whole
distillery the whole shebang to his two
nephews one of them being LEM Motlow LEM
Motlow buys out the other nephew and
again if you look at the at the bottle
you'll see LEM Motlow proprietor on it
because it's LEM who carries the torch
through prohibition and through World
War two now Jack sells out in 1907
Tennessee goes effectively dry in 1909
ten years before national prohibition
it's a heartbreaker for Jack he dies in
1911 at a relatively young age and what
you'll find out in the book is that he
did not die from kicking us safe as
legend has it but I won't give away how
he did LEM Motlow dies in 1947 and his
four sons take over the business they
sell out to brown-forman
which is based in Louisville and it's
brown foreman who who really has the
money to put into marketing this product
and one of the first things they do is
create the Tennessee Squires do we have
any Squires here we have to have a few
of course they're everywhere and that's
you know it's a fan club for for Jack
Daniels drinkers but there's a great
story associated with it that that I'll
wrap up with here Boris Yeltsin the
President of Russia is he's on his
deathbed at least everyone thinks he is
you know half dozen years or so ago and
so that their their secret police are
going through his personal papers
because he's a shady guy and they just
want to make sure there's nothing in
there they have to worry about when
Boris dies that and that might become
public and what they find is a deed for
land in Tennessee so immediately the red
flags go up because you know it it's an
official deed right so red flags go up
they call the Russian embassy here in
the States that embassy in turn calls
down to the Czech Daniel distillery and
says what is going on here
and it turns out that that Boris was a
Tennessee Squire and the amazing thing
is I always figured him for a vodka
drinker but that just shows you the kind
of mystique Jack Daniels has now I'd
happy to be happy to answer any
questions you have about the research
and Jack Daniel the company today how
they make their whisky whatever you
would like yes you mentioned that a
whiskey was made out of corn which of
course is the basis for bourbon but Jack
Daniels this difference that it is
filtered through charcoal right gives
you the particular flavor can you
comment on that sure a hundred years ago
Jack Daniels was a bourbon okay same
tradition 50 had to be 51% corn had to
be aged in charred white oak barrels now
the difference is and this is called the
Lincoln County process that's the
filtering through the pulverized
charcoal that's made from the sugar
maple tree now that Jack Daniel
distillery to say it decided that
whatever reason they had a finer product
because of that filtering and they
wanted to be recognized as something
other than bourbon
so they actually applied to the federal
government to be recognized as Tennessee
whiskey as opposed to bourbon so so
that's what happened that that's how
that occurred but you know bourbon every
everyone was making bourbon then yes I
was just devastated when you said that
he didn't die from kicking that safe
I have heard Sammy gulley talk about on
the Jack Daniels tour more times than I
can count and he always says that he got
gangrene in his big toe from kicking
that safe and so
did he die from gangrene he did not from
kicking the safe he kicked that safe in
either like 1905 1906 according to the
legend now you know he didn't die until
1911 that's a long time for the gangrene
to work its way up from his big toe I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna depress you with
with how he got it but it's in there
it's in the book yes yes you had said
that he was born in 18-49 and and
everyone I mean all the things say he
was born in 1850 what is the well in
eighteen 1850s in a nice round number
you know but what what I found was his
sister's diary and and back then in
Diaries you recorded when people were
born when they died and the weather and
everything else like that that would
appear to be mundane and his sister
records exactly when their mother died
and it was in January don't quote me on
this because I don't quite remember the
date but it was in 49 and then so
obviously he had to have been born prior
to that and then when you go to the
census records he is a year old in 1850
and local folks went around doing you
know canvassing the homes to put
together these census so you have to
pretty much assume that they knew the
Daniel family and knew when he was born
other questions yes
did he develop the sour mash process and
and did he start with that sour mash
process in his business he didn't
develop it that was already being used
at the time and that this outlet for
those of you don't know the sour mash
process is when you if you use some of
the leftover beer which is what what
you're making when when you create the
mash before you distill it use some that
leftover and put it into the next batch
to create it like a continuity and it
gives you a slightly smoother whiskey
versus a sweet so that was part of the
Lincoln County process and then that you
know it been a tradition for a while
other questions
I'm trying to get some idea of how big a
businessman he was what was the most
number of people that he had working for
him in in so far as you've been able to
find out probably a dozen at the most it
did not take a lot of people to run a
distillery and he capped off his
production of 300 gallons a day because
he wanted to stay a fine whiskey he
wanted to be known as making it in
batches as opposed to a big outfit so
that was all he really needed and you
know if you go to a distillery today
that you don't need a whole lot of
people to run it I will say it was a
very savvy businessman Dan call whom he
lived with for a while
dan calls uncle actually invested in
stocks and was very sophisticated and
businessman himself so Jack's business
education was excellent
you know homeschooled but he had a very
good picture of the business world
well mostly grass roots you also
advertised in newspapers and back then
you know people bought it in bulk the
grocers bought it in bulk the saloons
bought it in bulk and then they put it
into their own bottles or jugs so you
really were more of a wholesaler as
opposed to you know trying to attract an
individual customer and it's not till
the late 1890s when bottles come into
play in the bottle and bond act which
you'll read about in the book where the
distillers are now putting their own
labels on on the bottle with slogans and
and pictures and and that sort of thing
so that that was really towards the
twilight of his career when that started
to happen was the cave spring that's
used now used in the earlier processing
at the distillery well beginning in 1884
it was prior to that he was on what's
known as still house Creek out by the
Dan Kahl farm
anybody else questions okay well I
really appreciate your time and it's
been a pleasure